a retired flight attendant is walking  between boston and new york to honor the  crew members lost in the 9 11 terror  attacks  paul venito says he's making the trip  rain or shine pushing a beverage cart  he says he knew many of the flight crews  who died that day and used to fly that  route very often and he just happened to  have the day off that september  benito says it's mind-blowing how his  friends  they were doing their jobs not knowing  if they would survive or not  they're supposed to recognize those  people it's just the way it happened  they weren't recognized so now it's  happening today and i'm so grateful for  that  benito says he's picking up tips from  experts and strangers along the way he  left boston this past saturday and has  his trip planned out and if all goes to  plan  he should reach ground zero by september  11th